what's your process for developing an
idea oh that's difficult like what are
you doing before you write the
screenplay well I'll come up with an
idea right or I'll come up with a
character or I'll come up with a theory
and most of the time for me it's like
it's a thesis it's something and I think
that might be because I I read I love to
read so much literature and I'm gonna
kind of come from philosophy that I
develop a thesis or something that I
want to say and then I find characters
that I think I can embody that purpose
and that that can function in a story
that kind of carries this idea
throughout it so I can communicate what
I want to say in a story and through
characters so always come starts with an
idea or a thesis or a theory that I want
to talk about and the characters in the
story kind of all fall in line from
there then I'll just you know kind of
binge watch a bunch of movies that apply
and I'll just write you know I carry a
little notebook around me everywhere I
go so I don't really type that much I
mean I type but I I don't really write
my script until I've written it
handwritten it a bunch of times and a
bunch of different ways and I've kind of
flushed out my characters and that only
then do I write the plot because I think
that Lisa right now in the stories that
I'm trying to tell it's the characters
motivate the plot rather than the plot
motivating the characters I want to
really know my characters like they're
friends of mine like they're my best
friends my childhood friends and so once
I know them I kind of know the world
once I know the world I know the story
so that's my process interesting do you
ever get lonely when you finish writing
something because they were like you're
your best friend almost because you've
in a sense if it stops you're almost
losing them for a little bit
yeah I'm not really thought about it
like that you know you cut it you kind
of after you finish a film which finish
the script are kind of like uh what now
you know what do I do now because you're
like spent this like three month period
of time every day thinking about these
characters thinking about writing and
think about what's next thing about how
they say this thing about they say that
so yeah when it's done you're kind of
like oh man it I don't want it to be
over yet you know and I think it's the
same thing when you finish a film you're
like oh my god done shooting like that's
it it happened so quickly see that's why
you got to get into editing so you can
keep it alive somehow and then by the
time you're done you've got this file
that it's like a hundred and twenty
gigabytes and it took you a year and a
half to make it and you know
like a year and a half my life turns
into a 120 gigabyte file or a DVD so
it's kind of a weird sensation that you
have when you're like all this boil down
to this little thing that you can
double-click in a place and you just put
it in the DVD player plays but I think
that's kind of what the whole process is
it justifies it justifies you know the
characters that you want to write it's
because they do get to play they do get
to be on a big screen they do get to go
someplace and other people can watch and
live and experience it for like the two
hours so although like when you're done
with the script it's kind of over it's
not really over because your audience
gets to live through them your audience
gets to view it and that's like the
second reincarnation of your film it's
like having other people be touched by
what you've made
you